the thing I need to say before we
actually begin dig into this is I know
many of you have met this topic already
okay I just want you to forget
everything you have ever heard about
this just like slope okay um the biggest
danger especially with a class like this
is to approach this this topic is just
like a set of rules basically set of
rules memorize the rules know how to
apply them to you know hundreds
thousands maybe situations and then
that's it you know calculus nothing
could be further from the truth
okay um the design and the use of
calculus is such a creative process that
to just reduce it down to okay like you
will learn rules we will learn rules but
if learning rules is what calculus is to
you then you turn to what calculus is
okay so now pick up your hand and let's
think about what this is calculus is
actually an abbreviation the full name
that goes is infinitesimal calculus now
the reason why like this is what we're
actually going to be infinitesimally
calculus but as you can see it doesn't
exactly roll off the tongue okay uh
because of such a long awkward phrase
calculus is just what it came to know
but that's a bit weird calculus is a
very general word it's a the same word
where we get the word calculator from
and calculate in fact um before the
1600s calculus if she said calculus now
basically being the same as maths it's
it's is calculating stuff right the
reason why calculus means maths is
because calculus it's actually a latin
word it means um is latin for our small
pebble and you're like what does it see
what does that have to do with anything
and um there goes my school I think
small pebbles small pebbles are what we
used to calculate with in the early days
in ancient Rome right they get a whole
bunch of um a whole bunch of small
pebbles right and some some smart guy
and some some country I don't know its
name put all these pebbles on like rows
and move them around and Colton abacus
okay
tall pebbles are useful for counting and
for calculations right um by the way
it's also where we get the same word
chalk talk calc you get it
in fact if any of you ever become
calcium that's exactly right if any of
you become dentists or go to the dentist
they might say oh you have calculus on
your teeth but by the way not a good
thing because you're not good to have
small pebbles on your teeth like it's a
it's a it's you know all of the gross
stuff which is not meant to be Darrin
it's damaging your teeth okay so
calculus right it's really this word for
calculation and the fact that it took
over like what we're about to do this
little subtopic it took over from like
can you imagine like okay mathematics is
a really really big word right and if
just one little topic in mathematics
became called mathematics right what
does that say about all of the other
things right it says like this is really
really important we have many branches
of mathematics right calculus is just
one of them each of them is sort of
keyed into one single big idea okay you
think about this with me geometry for
instance we're familiar geometry when
you think geometry you think shapes
right you think shapes things that take
up space right shapes plane and space
right that's what geometry is about
dimensions are like empathy our drive
this is a bit trickier right but all
those X's and Y's and pronin was a nun
bones what they're really about is
quantities that are related to each
other things that change together in
proportion to each other in inverse
proportion to each other all those kinds
of things they're related the algebra
will help you understand probability
that's a bit of an easier one it's the
mathematics of what change
chance uncertainty right when you're
like I'm not sure something is going to
happen but I can know like the basics of
like this is more likely to happen less
likely to happen am I going to win the
lottery or not we're gonna get need
tired no nope no 5 etc each branch of
mathematics has its key idea calculus
calculus is the mathematics of all
things that change all things that
change and you know what there's lots of
things in the world any of the universe
that change so you can kind of imagine
why cockers kind of took over in fact
number one the preliminary nature see
courses that you're doing mathematics
and mathematics extension one are called
the calculus courses they're good 7080
percent plus calculus and it's like
subtopics okay in fact the equivalent
and what you guys are learning in
America is called AP calculus the AP
stands for advertisement right it means
it means where you know you guys we
don't mess with you guys you go to
Souter that yeah that's okay the course
is called calculus in some ways like so
is ours it's just it's just not given it
yes right there's there's precalculus
and then there's calculus right it's
like this is the things prepare you for
this okay our cactus you need to know
you need to know it was are developed
not jointly but independently by two
guys in two countries at exactly the
same time there's a huge argument
between these two as to who invented it
are by the way before was called
calculus called the calculus the beans
like a you know capital C cutters are
the two guys are one you may have heard
of a guy named Isaac Newton guy in
England right you might you might have
heard of him
the other guy the other guy you call a
doctor
cuddle Gottfried live knits okay German
guy Newton in England Leibniz in Germany
and both of them jointly so not only
simultaneously develop this this big
idea okay and I'll tell you later on
that's what you could remind me why it's
unusual that no one's heard of magnets
and everyone's heard of new okay so
here's the problem
and this is the famous part that on
though he's trying to work out so um
Newton well actually yes Newton was
sitting under a tree my or so the story
goes right and IV saw the Apple fall
from the apple tree it fell to the
ground is not what happened it's a it's
a story ah the apple fell to the ground
where where it actually you know hit is
up to debate or whether water actual app
or not it's on the debate but the poem
is that he watched the Apple fall and he
watched her fall the ground he's like
okay I'm grabbing grab is a thing
it makes the Apple fall but then as he
watch the Apple fall he thought the moon
is way up there right and it's also
being held in place by the same thing
that makes the Apple fall right gravity
but it doesn't it doesn't hit the earth
why does it do that
why does gravity do do this to this
object but that object just stays way up
there and he's like how do I have I woke
this up so what he did was um try as
we've been doing to take a problem which
you don't know how to phrase and turn it
into home which you can phrase because
then you can solve it you ran into a
problem gravity does something unusual
it does something like this um gravity
like most forces in the universe is are
inversely proportional to the force that
it exerts on something is even worse ly
proportional based on the UM I was going
to any business it's really the square
of the distance you are away from
something okay so the further away you
get something from something so if I
have over here
distance as your distance increases the
force of gravity and actually everything
really if you think of the electrostatic
force it's our Coulomb's law I think it
gets it gets smaller and smaller as well
it drops off like this
okay drops off quite fast okay now here
is his problem right he was trying to
work out okay how do these things relate
to each other right how does how does
gravity change over distance right this
is the problem he was trying to solve
and this is tricky because this thing
this thing is changing at different
rates everywhere that you look right for
example if you just compare it with this
straight line you can draw one of these
for me okay first straight line if you
want to know how this straight line is
changing okay that's not hard to work
out that's not hard to work out you just
see for example at a particular point in
distance time whatever value you compare
it to another point okay and if you've
got two points on there you can just say
look I'll just compare how much it
changes in one quantity versus how much
it changes in the other you just get
them as a ratio right we know that
measure ratio by the name start of the G
radians right are they armed on a
Cartesian plane you'd say look this is
vertical so you call that rise and this
is horizontal we call that run okay and
the gradient which is M still who knows
why okay the gradient is just the ratio
between those two things okay but
there's a problem here there's a problem
here no matter which two points you pick
you're always going to get a different
value so the thing about this the reason
why this works is because I can
calculate that or I can calculate
between these two points or I can
calculate between these two points and
you're always going to get the same
value I always get the same gradient
it's going to be this constant right we
know how to read that off but here we
have some trouble here we have some
trouble so here is what you can did and
it's ingenious
think about think about a circle okay
yeah thumb battle all right now what he
really wanted was how much how much am i
changing I mean any given point right
now by grading you guys already know in
terms of like geometry like what does
that look like it's the steepness of the
graph right if you can know how steep
something is at a given point that it's
green so he wanted to know like I know
obviously it's steep over here and it's
not so steep over here but how much okay
so what he was really after the quantity
he was after was the gradient of the
tangent okay this is a really critical a
deep breath agree imitator the problem
with working out the gradient of a
tangent is that gradient is rise over
run you have to have some run you have
to have two points like to compare
between y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 you
need a y2 and x2 but a tangent by
definition does it have two points it's
just got one right in fact that's why
it's the word tangent is even though
just like all of this right we have
another one now you wish languages
tongue which comes from the same root as
tangent is there no it is don't use very
often admit of it and here tangerine
tangible tangible what does tangible me
it means you can touch it you can touch
it right so a tangent is something which
just touches one point okay so this
presents problems for us and mutant
trying to work on like this try to work
out what's the gradient at that point
because there are no two points to
compare by definition so here's what
they both you